turn to my left and I see one of my
favorite people on planet Earth he'll be
spending will be spending an absurd
amount of time on live television
together on Sunday an eight and a half
hour edition of NFL gameday morning at
9:00 Eastern Time good to see all of
Famer Kurt Warner how are you sir I'm
great man how are you when you see this
trophy between us what do you think this
baby and you see reflection in right now
I would like one more chance to win one
of those is what I think is that really
every year I mean you don't miss a lot
of parts of the game and we cover it I
mean we we do a lot of things I go to a
lot of the games but every year Super
Bowl when we step onto that field on
Sunday morning that's the one thing I
think I think I just want to compete for
one more opportunity to win that thing I
mean that that's what it's all about and
you even feel it even though I'm
covering it now been out of the game for
eight years that's still what I think
every time I step on the field Super
Bowl Sunday eight years huh eight years
now yeah we've been working together
eight years yeah we've been together
well I wasn't working with you I wasn't
quite on your level right at the
beginning so maybe about six years it
took me a couple years to work my way up
but I made it
ah do you ever dream of itself do you
ever dream of it and wake up that's
right I'm not playing anymore
does that ever no no no it doesn't I
mean but there are times where I go out
and throw it in the backyard with my
kids and I write I think I want to do
this I just want somebody I won't
somebody that open up camp for me so I
can just do another seven on seven and
just see if I could still do it one more
time and then maybe consider it come
back it
I mean Brady's doing it 40 I'd be 47
that's right that's right why not I go
back on my back come back right maybe
need to play don't start with just a
seven on seven opportunity yeah do you
have a good relationship with Vince
McMahon
oh yeah we're close so I can sweep this
out just no wonder planning XFL come
back that's a horrible actually no tweet
that out okay and put in put the fire
emojis all that I'm totally doing please
do that see how that is you know I go in
the backyard throw it around with my
kids you dope hoping I thought that was
your nanny
come on now you shared that story
everyone in Chris have you heard this
story oh I've heard this story with my
boys Xander and Cooper throw it around
there now Taylor mud my daughter likes
to be involved in this throwing around
and I throw it around and we gotta send
this army the whole way better car
excuse me surrogate I'm sorry
so I tell him how to grip the football
and put your fingers on it but ya know
how to hold it with your fingers on the
strings but towards the back of the ball
because I have heard it from you okay
okay I pick up what you put down is
slightly so we go in the backyard we're
winging it around it's great one day
Cooper comes during I think was
championship Sunday last year two years
ago whatever and and he's throwing it
around in studio in the commercial break
and he's doing it right in front of all
the guys sitting on the game day morning
set well I'm on a different part of the
set getting rid doing on camera leading
and this was awesome my proud moment
here's my son he good spiral too right
look good that's I mean that's why I had
to ask him see cou what had asked him go
ahead you guys I wouldn't ask him I said
oh where did you learn to throw because
I mean you know Rich's chest sure was
getting big cuz aiming it goes way back
to a few years ago when we did the you
remember that build on the dunk takes
exactly and rich missed by 20 feet
giving him crap ever since
yeah when his son comes in and he's
winging around like wow I mean what rich
must be getting better he must be
teaching his kid so I asked him work
where did you learn to throw it like
that and without hesitation his response
was what rich my nanny Katie Katie I
will never forget that that was that was
beautiful that was of course I'm like oh
she must throw a pretty good spiral
anyway Kurt Warner how do you see this
game playing out first blush Jimmy give
me what I'm gonna be hearing on the
Thursday meeting for our Sunday show
what do you got for me I could talk
about this game and all the ins and outs
forever but I tell you what I love the
matchup I know we got this whole
underdog thing going with the Eagles I
really believe the Eagles have a chance
I think there's certain matchups that
play to their favor in this game like
what well I mean I think the fact that
the Patriots play a lot of man-to-man
coverage and I know a lot of people say
well they change it up all the time but
if you watch them all year long they
weren't real good at the beginning of
the year and they've really settled in
on playing a lot of man coverage I think
there's some great matchups on the
outside for the Eagles Nick Foles having
to read coverages if you know you're
gonna get man coverage a lot it keeps
things a lot simpler I love the you know
the front five guys are the Eagles
against the front seven of the Patriots
they're not great at getting pressure on
the quarterback so those are things that
I like I mean we always talk about
matchups defensively against Brady got
to be good up the middle and that's
where the Eagles are really good
defensive wise is up the middle now
there's some holes on the back end so I
feel like Tom Brady's gonna have some
success as well but I just think there's
some good matchups in this game that
that play to the fact that this could be
a really really good football game and
you know maybe come down to Nick Foles
having to make those plays that Tom
Brady usually makes it those moments
well what would you Kurt Warner give
advice to Nick Foles what pieces of
advice would you give to this kid who is
a chance to complete write a magic
carpet ride in the biggest spot what do
you think raise e I mean it's crazy for
him I think the advice I would give him
is you have to be yourself in these
moments and what does that mean it's
it's kind of twofold you have to come
out and be aggressive and attack early
in this game and you know you have to
feel like you can make all the plays you
can't hesitate because those who
hesitate are lost and you know the flip
side of that is you can't be so worried
about making the mistake that's gonna
lose the Super Bowl that you make the
mistake that's gonna lose the Super Bowl
and I think it's so easy to get in these
moments and kind of feel it out and
play not to make that mistake and by
that point you know Tom Brady is gonna
be in a position to take this thing from
you so you have to come out and let the
game come to you don't try to do too
much don't do too little but stay
aggressive early in this game and play
the way I mean think about Nick Foles is
you look back he's been really good at
taking care of the football you know
he's been really good at making good
decisions now just add in those big play
decisions that you made last week or in
the championship game and I think you've
got a real chance to compete in this
who's your x-factor
who's my x-factor by the way as you know
Mariucci is a very difficult time x-pac
his x-factor Tommy
cows Kia we had to is a matter of fact
literally put a definition of x-factor
on the screen during our championship
Sunday game day morning but I think just
ended two minutes ago and we still read
it wrong
so who's somebody that we should look
out for yeah we're not gonna say no Cory
Clements that's what I say plays he's a
guy that can get outside and if you
watch where the patients have struggle
done their linebackers in coverage yes
and you know the crazy thing is they
don't use them as much because they have
a je in blood but you know but I just
think if you could find a way to mix him
in there and you go back to the Miami
game Miami game they beat him down there
pressure up the middle and then they use
Kenyan Drake on the edges and made big
plays with him in the passing game as
well as the run game he's a guy that I
think you should look for do you know
who told me that Cory Clement would be a
great x-factor my nanny Katy find a way
to get her on the show she can wing it
around she can run a demo and then we
can put her in for the X Factor sound no
she's coming from Warner's corner next
see what her knowledge is beyond that
but she can she can definitely run a
demo she can throw spirals hot now I can
take a break and during the television
only segment we're gonna bring j.b
smoove out here the last time you guys
were hooked up together
I was asking where's the field at I'm
thinking we ought to go stop traffic out
front here but in the road like we did
when we were growing up and but then you
realize you're a dome quarterback and
you're not going out it's on a Krakken
with JV smooth again now we're gonna
finish up the show with Kurt and JB as
JB has the list of questions that he did
not ask wound up on the cutting room
floor of last night's media session on
behalf of the Rich Eisen show that's
next here from Minneapolis
all right sort of a reunion here from
our our Houston Super Bowl segment look
at it where JP smooth JB Smoove and Kurt
Warner were a receiver quarterback
tandem Aeneas Williams wearing his Hall
of Fame gold jacket yeah on defense and
they didn't work out so well for I'm
living on myself you know I went out
there I'm gonna blame it on you have
boots cowboy boots on he had on sneakers
so he had more grip you know yeah well
you couldn't you couldn't you couldn't
get loose and then it seems like Kurt
you weren't expecting him to curl back
you know it was supposed to be pushed to
the corner and he and I messed it up
talk about this chemistry thing we just
talked about that last segment chemistry
right exactly so I mean he's a pizza
it's already in rap on the ballot and he
was about to get in or he didn't know at
the time so you're taking the blame it
was a poor lad no I said with emotion I
should have got more now is any five
yards after contact all right just bring
to the outside he had him that way he
had him there was heavy pass at the
first now don't get me bro who are
leaning you had him perfectly woulda
just got back to the corner I said cut
through the corner yeah yeah the route
wasn't the best it wasn't you don't have
hardly ever hear receiver says
you're listening to the Rich Eisen show
yes we were in the home of the big game
in the home of my pillow as well we're
gonna see the folks of my pillow on
Friday's show they're gonna stop by and
we've been talking about my pillow for
well over a couple of years now the buy
one get one free tab still there for the
clicking at my pillow calm you put in my
promo code of rich you buy one my pillow
premium pillow you get the second one
absolutely free with a 10 year warranty
in 60 day money back guarantee do it
right now I promise you my pillow will
become your pillow Kurt Warner and JB
Smoove Kurt finishing up the show JB's
been with us all three hours after last
night always thought they would go to
work baby go to art to see JB's work
we'll be tweeting it out as well at Rich
Eisen show and Curt you and I are gonna
be working for eight and a half hours on
Sunday a divorce do you know where Steve
Mariucci and Michael Irvin are right now
I have a feeling that are they efficient
they are shooting an ice-fishing right
now I love it this is Irving his soup
for must be great to he before me what
what was the stupidest question you were
asked that media day when you were up on
a pond remember you know I think just
the most off-the-wall one was if I was a
cartoon character
who would I be and what I said Bugs
Bunny because he's kind of the you know
the head of Looney Tunes and you know
head of the group and so ok well with
Bugs Bunny yeah alright what what
cartoon would you be JB could we do of
course what's the of course you know for
some reason that dog stands up on its
hind legs and I'll have a same kind of
face what would I be
scrappy-doo no I wouldn't scrappy-doo
come on what cartoon character I'd be
Superman ask you the question
Superman rich you remind me of Superman
who should I be he does remind you mom
you smell that they're both I'm plus one
enough the commissioners suite for the
Super Bowl
so they're trying character that you
pick is the right idea list of questions
that did not make your cut JB Smith all
don't make it do you want me to another
time won't be to go through it for how a
pulley Vaati vitai okay are you sure you
don't have your last name first in your
first name last this is good clarity
from the Garrett Blount you played with
the Pats they know you over there a few
guys are down by a lot at halftime would
you try to sneak back into the Pats
locker room and hope nobody notices
those earrings like a Costanza moment
right genius move Danny Amendola you
asked this one you remember this which
one you were gonna ask him do I want you
to say are you better now or when you
were Wes Welker or Julian Edelman what's
a gut-check versus a belly check what is
that okay first half mmm you know
Belichick you know this genius of a
coach gives other coach a gut check
right hmm at the halftime you know
belcheck does a little his little
changes and now that other coach is
doing Belichick Belichick and so hashtag
that - hashtag this goes with Belichick
perfect perfect dog mask school if you
win but if you lose will it be a small
village overseas wearing Eagles
Superbowl jerseys and dark masks once
you lose everybody knows all that loser
gear goes overseas to help these
countries it's true there's gonna be a
bunch of bunch of people wearing
philadelphia eagles and those dogmas
yeah they lose so will you when you
introduce something like that to the
equation you have to be ready if you
lose the speedos max mass laying around
you know it'll be laying around
and last one JB I've got about 30
seconds halftime show they missed a huge
opportunity without what opportunity
trance hologram yeah don't tell anybody
just the pris hologram walk out just
like blue afro everything the glasses
the long coat it's walk on stage prints
are number one seed advancing in the
Mall of America region the greatest
Minnesota icon ever voted Kevin McHale
versus Judy Garland by the way we were
doing a little bracketology on that f
scott Fitzgerald beat Jack Morris and
Paul Molitor to advance to take on Bob
Dylan or Lindsey Vonn Thank You JB for
everything thank you my friend I also
want to thank Alex Smith Steve Smith
senior and Brian Billick on tomorrow's
show DeMarcus Ware at Gregg Olson Jerome
Bettis Travis Kelce cam Jordan and
Willie McGinest on Thursday Terrell
Davis Luke Kuechly Emmitt Smith Deion
Sanders Tony Dungy LaDainian Tomlinson
Jim Kelly and Aaron Rodgers that's our
role in the next two days join us on
Wednesday show from Minneapolis so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience